today is the twelfth anniversary of the  Madrid bombings where hundred and  ninety-one Spanish citizens were killed  and many were wounded and it is to  commemorate the victims of the Madrid  bombyx but it is also the day to  commemorate the victims of all terrorist  attack in the world and and fourthly  2015 has been a terrible year started  with terrorist attack in Paris ended up  with terrorist attack in Paris but we  have seen terrorist attack in Beirut in  the Sinai in Ankara in Istanbul in  Africa we want to share a thought and a  full solidarity with the victims all  over the world most of them being Muslim  and I just want to reiterate the strong  determination of the European Union  which has in 2015 and in this year  mobilized always resource in support of  the members say so that we address the  root causes present more people from  getting radicalized but also to fight  terrorism effectively in Europe and  outside Europe